paint this picture for me so Mr so Mr
Wright how how tall is Mr Wright um
around six foot I mean I'm not really
picky when it comes to that actually
really tall guys kind of scare me okay
so round six foot but not like seven
foot tall okay um build like what kind
of physique do you like do you like a
bodybuilder do you like a swimmer's body
do you like a dad B do you like a guy
shaped like a pair like what's your
what's your um athletic okay so swimmers
body sure okay and how much does he have
to
make cuz you got to travel you got to do
cool [__] you're going to be together
monogamous all that all that fun stuff
gotta get some toys for the Kink it's
gonna cost some
money I
think anywhere from
like 50 to 150 or more 50 to 150 is a
big spread what do you do for I'm not
really picky when it comes to that
because like I already support myself
okay so I don't need what do you do for
a living I'm a nurse uh okay and what
like can you give me a range on what
that pays where you live because I don't
know what that pays in Texas I know here
they make like 100 to 150,000 depending
on what kind of work they're they're
doing is it in that
range Okay cool
so so you're in 100 100
150 okay and the guys you said 27 to 40
right no kids yeah and he doesn't and
and he can't want
kids right okay so let me ask you this
question so you're a nurse and what do
you bring to the table to the
relationship for
him
um I mean I'm loyal honest I'm fun um
someone that they can have a
intellectual conversation with and have
that deeper conversation someone that's
going to bring new things to the table
um I'm funny I
think so you've got loyal honest fun a
man can get a dog for
that um intellectual conversation you
can have that with his friends with men
um funny he'll get that from a standup
comedy
so what do you bring to the table
outside of that as a woman I'm also
feminine
and
um chat would you describe Candace as
feminine I'm not looking at the chat M
you can tell me when the chat SS to
chime in but I'm just curious what the
viewers think of it
so so feminine how long you been a nurse
for um for right under under five years
five
years and kids are definitely off the
table that's like a no-go zone for you
right do you like to cook I do are you a
good cook I think I
am do you subscribe to the notion of
blue jobs and pink jobs or are you more
of like uh I'll handle a few the these
things and I want you to do these things
and maybe you'll be cooking and do the
dishes sometimes and I'll be taking out
the garbage sometimes
um I think it's like a give and take
kind of thing it's like I definitely
enjoy just completely doing it myself at
times and kind
of being creative in that
aspect and then I
also enjoy sitting back and helping or
assisting as well what's the chat say m
we've got one here about the tattoos I'm
G to count that as a NE no for one but
then we
have a yes so we're we're even okay all
right
um you're you're fully independent like
how long have you lived by yourself um
for almost five years do you own your
own house um I have my own place yes
okay so he would have to have his own
place too
right um would you would you date down
to a guy I mean because you said that
it' be okay if you made $50,000 a year
so if he had a six foot tall athletic
guy 30 years old no kids doesn't wad
kids likes travel but he makes 50 Grand
a year would you take that guy on in
your life he doesn't have a house he's
renting because he only makes 50 Grand a
year um I mean that still someone that I
would be interested in dating that's not
really like a no for me that but dating
is not a long-term relationship dating's
like I'm going to check you out and see
what you're made of right I still want
someone who who's still working on
trying to build up from that as well um
but if he was hot you would date him if
he was a hot
dude
there it's not just based off of looks
for me like there are other aspects of
that but he's only making $50,000 a year
so he's got to bring something to the
table he doesn't have a house he's got a
regular job is he interesting is he
adventurous there's something
interesting about him but he's only
making 50 Grand a year he's a
good-looking dude
is I mean there's also the confidence
Factor like are they a confident guy um
no no I know but I mean you you did say
that you would date him but it was like
a hesitant dat him like it's not
somebody I would kind of take seriously
I would I would look at him see what
he's made of does he ambitious maybe I'm
sort of picking up like is that what I'm
getting like does he have a future does
he have potential right yeah like I want
to see that there's drive that there's
ambition what about like a 40-year-old
guy that's got potential like if he made
$50,000 a year like you met a guy that's
40 he good-looking he's six foot he
doesn't want kids but he makes $50,000 a
year at 40 would you have patience for
potential with a 40-year old guy
yeah I
would cenace are you the type
that you prefer you know if you had your
perfect world you say LTR longterm
relationship you know are you willing to
sort of go along with I I hesitate to
use the term submit because everybody
hates that word but I'll say it you know
submit to a guy's leadership you know if
this is a guy that you choose to be with
and you want to be with you you have
these accolades and you make a good
living and you have you know these
things to your name but it sounds like
you still maybe want to have a guy that
is capable of making plans and making
decisions and you sort of going along
with the flow is that right right oh
yeah like definitely because I'm someone
that I'm so in charge of everything else
in my life I want to be able to come
into the relationship and turn that
aspect of my brain off but do you think
that you would be able to take Direction
and sort of take guidance from a guy
that has yet to have it all figured out
from a guy that's making a half a third
or half as much money as you're making
maybe he hasn't been to as many places
as you have
maybe is not as experienced with the
Kink dynamic as you are you know so I
think I think what we're trying to get
at here is that I don't know if I'm
convinced that you would
be necessarily saddled with a guy
who isn't kind of a level above you in a
way because I I hear you yeah I want to
be submissive I want to kind of I do all
this other stuff I I'm in a job where
I'm constantly having to kind of wear
the pants so to speak so i' and we hear
that from a lot of women that are in
high-paying careers like they do this
very above the shoulders acidic
masculine stuff all day at work and the
last thing they want to do is come home
and have to play quarterback for their
own
relationship but is there a part of you
maybe that would see a guy that doesn't
have it figured out doesn't have the
things you've got doesn't make the money
you
make do you think maybe you have an
issue or have trouble letting that guy
drive the car while you're the p
yeah I'm not going to lie like it's it's
not meant to be a gotcha it's just yeah
it's not a stumper it's just I think
that's something that we try to get at
here is like yeah like maybe you'd have
patience for the guy to kind of figure
it out but that that expiration date of
him figuring it out is is is a short
Runway especially if that guy's an older
guy because you want to you don't want
to come home and tell this guy how to
date you you want a guy that already
knows how I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out